grande nouvelle aujourd'hui les quelques
jours je vous annonçais sur une vidéo
qu'on allait lancer une soirée on va
faire une grande soirée avec un réel
ariel gomez qui a un média s'appelle
retail numérique vous inviterai à livrer
la vidéo joue bien je sais pas là où
dans la description une grande soirée
autour de la téléphonie téléphonie
mobile c'est la grande soirée retail de
la téléphonie mobile qui a lieu le 10
décembre prochain avec plein d'acteurs
du secteur de la téléphonie mobile
une soirée qui a réservé aux
professionnels on va avoir plein de
monde centaine de personnes et justement
durant cette soirée on va remettre des
prix pour remettre les prix des
téléphones des meilleurs téléphones de
l'année selon les catégories
et justement c'est vous qui allez
décider quelles vont être les lauréats
qui va gagner
dans quelle catégorie et c'est vous qui
allez voter et je serai maintenant pour
être là aujourd'hui parce que c'est
vraiment une interaction entre vous et
ça va impacter directement les
professionnels parce que vous allez
donner votre tour vous allez dire vous
je vote pour ce produit pour un autre et
ça va aller directement professionnels
comme ça ça va être vraiment cool vous
allez voter il ya un questionnaire qui
situe juste en bas je vais vous dire
quels sont les produits dans les
différentes catégories
vous êtes ensuite son questionnaire on
pourrait tout remplir vous votez vous
l'envoyez limer les connecter mais on
n'offre absolument rien il sera transmis
à personne c'est juste pour certifier le
vote vous êtes tranquille je suis
absolument aucun problème et ça va être
vraiment vraiment vraiment cool c'est
vous qui allez dire aux professionnels
je vote pour celui là parce que c'est le
meilleur et pas l'autre fusionnerait le
le résultat la soirée étant le 10
décembre au soir
vous me laissez un ou deux jours le
temps de monter tout ça et vous aurez un
débris conflit de la soirée vous saurez
qui sont les lauréats enfin tout ça va
être vraiment vraiment vraiment toulalan
[Musique]
tout mis dans mon ordinateur ici je
profite lâche une petite pause suis
passé au salon de la photo aujourd'hui
vous rome qui peut être plutôt
intéressant première catégorie c'est la
performance qu'elle est le smartphone le
plus performant de 2019 dans les choix
vous avez classé par ordre alphabétique
apple iphone os pro asus rog phone 2
asus zanfan 6 black shark de pro google
pixels 4 au nord view 20 ou whaou ep 30
pro nokia 9 pur view ou en plus c'est
trop au port et noack le zoom x 10
resort phone de samsung galaxy note 10
plus samsung galaxy s 10 sony xperia one
show mimi neuf dépôts première catégorie
la deuxième catégorie c'est sur la photo
quel est selon vous le meilleur
photophone de l'année 2010
on commence avec l'iphone ans pro google
pixels 4 au nord view 20 huawei p30 pro
nokia 9 pur view ou en plus c'est des
pros au port et nos dix fois zoom
samsung galaxy note dix plus chauds 8900
vraiment pas de commentaires pas du tout
orienté le vote je vous donne
directement ensuite l'écran quel
smartphone à une meilleur écran de
l'année 2019 apple iphone on se pro gold
pixels 4 web et 30 pro ou one + 7 tpr au
réseau phone de samsung galaxy fold
samsung galaxy note 10 plus sony xperia
où on arrive sur le design en plus quel
est le meilleur design selon vous pour
un smartphone de 2019
apple iphone oms pro asus rog phone deux
blagues chats 2 cros cole trekkeurs x4
nokia 9 pur view réseau phone de samsung
galaxy fold sony xperia web en continu
alors laquelle est le meilleur rapport
qualité prix en dessous de 600 euros
donc dans la tranche entre 300 à 600
euros parce que on ne tranche en tout
300 euros juste après mon réunir alors
faire fun 3 google pixels 3 à honor view
20 web et 30 light motorola onevision
nokia 9 pur view ou en plus c'est théo
port et nos deux samsung galaxy à 70
sony xperia 10
plus le chien 8,9 et on arrive dans la
fameuse catégorie d'entrée de gamme
quel est le meilleur rapport qualité
prix à moins de 300 euros alcatel 5v
asus iphone max pro n 2 au nord 9 x
huawei paceman z
motorola one macro nokia 6.2 au pot à 9
2020 samsung galaxy à 40
sony xperia l3 xiaomi renmin note 7 view
3 pro et en standard sur des accessoires
alors quel est selon vous l'accessoire
le plus innovant qui a un lien avec la
téléphonie mobile trottinette force move
suprême 6400 parce qu'elle a un chargeur
en tant que première charger votre
maintenant en adduction cudos power line
caire usb power charger eyed peas et
vous aurez tous vous verrez directement
acerbe et 130 est un projecteur kimball
c'est le pnj gimp mode x1 fitbit versa 2
mophie juice pack access samsung galaxy
watch active 2 on a une serrure
connectés parce que la maison connectée
aussi avec le smartphone la nuque qui
nous qui nous qui lui qui je pense ce
mark logue 2.0 cellule airlines wireless
passeport ça c'est pour les accessoires
et on arrive ensuite sur les coques
quelle est selon vous la meilleure
protection aux remarques de
constructeurs en garde bien des coques
d'accessoiristes alors on à la big ben
force kays urban 360 cudos optique garde
aux petits guarda infiniti glace allroad
mobile dx pour iphone cellular line
tetra force choc advance on alla gear4
crystal palace avec la techno 3d aux
auteurs box des fender spek président au
grip rhinochill solide suite
ensuite on a la catégorie sécurité
quelle est la meilleure solution de
protection logicielle contre les virus
et les malwares les attaques et
compagnie bitdefender mobile security
bitdefender box d'un f secure et secure
sense f secure d'eau talent kaspersky
security for mobile avast mobile ce qui
est mobile security et antivirus norton
avg anti-virus pour android mcafee total
protection pc pro technique chez data
mobilesecurity il est mobile security
pour android lookout mobile security
android et ios
un virage mobileye security aussi pour
on continue ensuite avec l internet
mobile quelle est la meilleure qualité
internet mobile que vous percevez vous
quel est selon vous le meilleur
opérateur haut niveau la qualité
internet mobile on parle bien des
opérateurs bouygues telecom free orange
sfr et ensuite au niveau des appels
qu'elle est la meilleure qualité les
appels perçu s wing orange sfr ou free
vous aimez le lien pour aller voter en
bas vous avez jusqu'à fin novembre pour
voter et parmi tous les votants vous
allez très compenser avec elle à des
cadeaux que vous allez avoir deux
smartphones de oppose ces deux reinoso
mpho 10 a gagné il y aura pas mal de
choses aura le tirage au sort qui aura
lieu bien évidemment à la fin du mois je
préviendrai lé gagnant directement par
email d'où l'intérêt aussi de donner
bien évidemment votre email je suis très
content vous puissiez prendre part vous
directement vous allez pouvoir impacté
les constructeurs impact et tout le
monde en donnant votre feedback en
donnant vos howard votre pays je vous
invite donc à venir voter vous avez le
lien en bas vous avez jusqu'à la fin du
mois
n'hésitez pas à le faire tourner autour
de vous qui est un maximum de personnes
qui découvrent qu'ils partagent et
qu'ils puissent voter comme ça on aura
un résultat qui sera très complet ça va
être vraiment irak ou pas là sur ce je
vous fais des gros bisous et je vous
donne rendez vous dès demain
bisous et ciao